die zahl der neuinfektionen innerhalb
der letzten 24 stunden liegt bei 14.000
54 vergleichen wir den wert mit dem wert
von vor einer woche also am vergangenen
dienstag da lag die neuinfektionen 213
1604 das heißt wieder mehr infektion als
letzte woche und das obwohl es ja schon
verschärfte maßnahmen gibt einen teil
locker und in ganz deutschland und
deswegen kein wunder dass jetzt wieder
über den knallharte lockdown gesprochen
wird sehr natürlich auch schon in
sachsen kommen soll und wenn wir auf die
deutschlandkarte schauen dann kann man
auch verstehen warum das so ist wenn
sich hier sehen wir ab dem wert von 50
gilt man als corona hotspot aber die
dunkel rot eingefärbten sind die
regionen die an effizienz wert von über
200 haben hier zum beispiel in bayern
main spessart aber ganz auffällig auch
die peak eingefärbten das sind nämlich
die korona super hot spots wenn man so
will mit einem incidents wert von über
500 zb bayern landkreis regen aber jetzt
kommt in sachsen gleich zwei davon
nämlich einmal sächsische schweiz
osterzgebirge mit einem incidents wert
von 500 8,17 und direkt nebenan ich muss
einmal kurz hier reinklicken landkreis
bautzen mit knapp 500 incidence wert und
deswegen eben kein wunder dass dort
jetzt gehandelt wird ab montag also der
knallharten lockdown in sachsen das hat
ministerpräsident kretschmann heute
verkündet die sächsische staatsregierung
hat heute entschieden dass wir dieses
land unseren freistaat sachsen jetzt zur
ruhe bringen müssen
es ist die einzige möglichkeit um dieses
infektionsgeschehen zu stoppen das ab
kommendem montag ab 14
dezember schulen kindergärten horte
geschlossen werden und dass auch der
einzelhandel bis auf die bereiche wie
dringend notwendig sind lebensmittel die
fragen des grund grundbedarfs
geschlossen werden das ist aus unserer
sicht notwendig um hier das
infektionsgeschehen zu brechen
also ab montag gnade hard lock down im
ganzen bundesland sachsen sowie man die
zahlen dort in den griff bekommen doch
es gibt auch jan region die ist ganz
anders
macht uns war es dass tübingen der
landkreis hier auch ein hoher
intelligenz wert von 109 aber schaut man
sich die zahlen etwas genauer an dann
sieht man dass sie mit einer anderen
strategie erfolg haben der entsetzen
darauf die älteren zu schützen besonders
eben die wohl nahe gruppe zu schützen
und das machen sie mit erfolg man sieht
nämlich seite mal gibt es keinen
einzigen corona fall mehr in
seniorenheimen altenheim die natürliche
so stark betroffen sind in vielen
anderen regionen also seit mai keinen
einzigen mehr das ist schon echt
erstaunlich und wenn man sich die
infektions anzahl schaut bei den über 75
jährigen dann liegt der bei null
ja wie haben sie das geschafft das
wollen wir uns genauer anschauen und das
sind nämlich die cola maßnahmen die
aktuell in tübingen gelten und zwar gibt
es dort eine extra einkaufszeit für
senioren für ältere menschen und zwar
sollen die nämlich von 9 bis 11 uhr
einkaufen gehen können ganz ungestört
eben dann nicht mit den ganzen massen
zusammen kommen die anderen soll zu
hause bleiben das ist keine vorschrift
aber ein appell und das funktioniert
anscheinend auch sehr gut
desweiteren der punkt zwei senioren
haben die möglichkeit sich ein taxi zu
rufen oder einen rufbus und müssen nicht
eben in volle bahnen bussen steigen und
das sogar zum preis eines normalen bus
tickets und weiterhin wird natürlich
auch viel getestet gerade in senioren-
und altenheimen aber nicht nur die
beschäftigen die bewohner und vor allem
auch die besucher werden dort getestet
und neu hinzugekommen ist der punkt
kostenlose schnelltests die werden jetzt
am marktplatz angeboten
dort kann sich nämlich jemand deren
angehörigen hat ihn besuchen möchte der
halt älter ist kostenlos ein schnelltest
abholen kommen und auch wichtige
schutzmaßnahme sind eben die fsp zwei
masken die kostenlos ausgegeben werden
nicht nur ins seniorenheim mittlerweile
auch in drogerien und auch in der tafel
war eben auch oft ärmere menschen sich
diese gut schützen der ffp zwei masken
nicht leisten können ja da fragt man
sich wenn das so gut funktioniert warum
machen dass nicht auch andere landkreise
dass sie sich eben darauf fokussieren
die älteren menschen zu schützen und zum
schluss und wollen wir noch einmal auf
die auslastung der krankenhäuser schauen
das ist ja auch eine wichtige kennzahl
im kampf gegen die cola pandemie dort
sehen wir das über 21.800 intensivbetten
derzeit in ganz deutschland belegt
daneben natürlich auch menschen drauf
die andere schwere erkrankungen haben
denn die zahl in gelb gibt an wie viele
menschen davon anwohner erkrankt sind
und eben intensivmedizinisch betreut
werden müssen
die blaue zahl ist ganz wichtig 5349
betten sind aktuell in ganz deutschland
noch frei dazu muss man aber auch sagen
dass es hierbei nur um die gemeldeten
intensivbetten geht wir sind bild und
wir liefert dir deine news auf youtube
zum nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren